all right, great to be back at it.
Audience questions missed three last week
because of the vacation, but I'm back.
These are good ones.
First question.
Hey David, what's the worst that could really
happen with a Bernie or Warren presidency
anyway?
Republicans are pretending like it could be
the end of the world.
What are people actually afraid of?
Are things so good right now that Bernie or
Warren might ruin everything?
This is very astute.
Um, when we think of the policies that somebody
like Bernie or Warren would put in place,
what is the worst that could happen?
Right?
I mean, listen, th there's the idea Democrats
won't protect us because they're too scared
to use the military.
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren, unlike
Donald Trump, don't believe that they are
the most knowledgeable people in the room
on every issue all the time.
They would follow the recommendations of the
military and intelligence community.
They would meet whatever threats our intelligence
community and the Pentagon and the Defense
Department present to them.
Period.
The idea that they are going to say, no, we're,
we're going to do nothing and let people just
to come on that, that that can't seriously
be a something.
Any thinking person believes is a risk.
Number two, they'll ruin the economy.
They're going to blow up the debt like every
other president has done other than Barack
Obama who actually slowed down the growth
of the national debt.
Historically, employment does better under
democratic presidents than Republican presidents.
The stock market does better under democratic
presidents than Republican presidents.
There is no evidence whatsoever to suggest
that we should be worried.
And as far as debt goes, the debt has been
exploding for how long has it been exploding?
The more we understand about debt, including
modern monetary theory, we understand that
just debt in and of itself, just the number
doesn't tell us whether the economy is doing
poorly or well or whether the president is
doing a good or a bad job.
Why are we deficits spending?
Is it economically stimulative?
If we are going to deficit spend, if it was
necessary to make sure everybody has healthcare,
that would be worth it.
Because people who are healthy work more,
they earn more money, they generate more tax
revenue for the government.
So again, the fears of a Democrat will destroy
the economy, are completely unfounded.
And so the worst case scenario of Bernie being
president or Warren being president, we'll
have more respect from other countries around
the world.
We will finally start making sense when it
comes to foreign policy and trade policy and
whatever else.
The worst cases, some of the programs that
Bernie or Warren want to do might end up not
completely paying for themselves.
And then we'll have a little bit more debt
like we do with every president.
I mean, I mean I, I'm, I'm being sort of facetious,
but also not, I mean, th th you're asking
the question in the exact right way.
What is the nightmare scenario of a Bernie
or a war in presidency?
There is no such nightmare scenario.
We're in the nightmare scenario right down
right now.
And I think it was Trump who said it didn't
Trump say to black people, why not vote for
me?
I mean, things haven't been going so well
for you guys anyway.
Have the uh, status quo center left to center,
right?
Presidents.
We've had really been working out that well
for everybody other than the richest.
I think the numbers make it pretty clear.
So yeah, it's good that you're being skeptical
of this idea that Bernie and Warren is presidents
are going to somehow destroy our way of life
and everything that we hold dear, it doesn't
make any sense.
The facts don't bear it out.
Don't even worry about that.